all right stephen
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally uh washington state on the
east side of the the state is actually
two different states you got the
liberals on the west and you got
all the conservatives on the east they
grow the best apples and asparagus
but yeah that's that's where i grew up
um a lot of chicanos
hispanic uh dominant where i grew up
and uh
i liked washington state you know i like
being from the west the west coast but i
lived all over man i was stationed in
california um
you know i lived in utah for a little
bit lived in idaho you're in the
military yeah i did four years in the
marine corps
i joined august 19
2001. i was in boot camp during
september 11th and we were actually the
last full workup cycle before the war
kicked off
in o3 and i was we're the first ones
across the border once the groundwork
started
but i went back in 0-4 um
unfortunately what happened when i came
back after my second deployment
and this is my
intake in my view of it now
the marine corps saw they couldn't get
another deployment out of me
so they decided at this time after two
two deployments of doing everything they
asked above and beyond decided this time
that i was gonna they're gonna pop me
for marijuana
when however the whole time
in the marine corps i smoked marijuana i
was hot for pot right out of boot camp
you know and
i did what they asked me to do
i was trained to do that i was behind a
50 caliber machine gun i had to i had to
put rounds down range i had to see
things that i'll spend the rest of my
life trying to forget and then
they failed to
take care of the transitioning when i
came home
they failed to offer anything their
their help was a
a march down to the chaplain and
got a hug from him
um
and
it kind of that kind of that was a
turning point in my life
um i realized that
you know
i had all this this uh camaraderie
and um
brotherhood and
and you know
value system of
don't leave a marine behind i felt like
i got left behind
you know and and uh
and i think i'm on my way back to to
taking care of that um
mark when you asked me to do this
interview
yesterday i started this program where
i'm going to be off crystal meth
for 30 days and and i'm going to imply
all the tools that i learned in in the
many rehabs that i've attended
and uh the principles that i already
know that that work um
by by praying all those little things
that you do throughout the day help you
stay sober and the biggest thing about
it is is being a service you know um
and i feel like
i can do that with with some of these
talents that that my father heaven has
given me
um i know that's i kind of just went all
over the place there for you but
so crystal meth has been in your life
for how long
uh when i got back from iraq in 04
um i went home
on post deployment leave
and
it's the first time i tried crystal meth
all my buddies that i smoked marijuana
with growing up and stuff
all were all pot heads right they were
all doing this drug
and i had no idea about it and my my
first intake was about a line that big
then i and i snort it that's how i like
to to use it
i don't shoot up and smoking's okay i
just don't really get
the effects that i like
from snorting it
and um
that's
eight hours of snorting that drug
i was i was gone i didn't have to
remember what happened in iraq i'd have
to remember
all all the the
the traumatic events right
and
i i realized i had a problem this drug
took over
and it's been a part of my life i've had
windows of sobriety since then
but not long enough to
to really
be the person i i know that i was
created to be
you know um
i i went on a two-year mission right
after that for the church of jesus
christ latter-day saints i was a mormon
missionary in texas
and uh and i was sober
and what i found is i was
serving other people every day
and i was never happier you know and and
that was the solution
and the cool thing about it is it's it's
actually the 12 steps that they teach
you in aaa
i was doing that i just didn't know it
at the time
um
previous or right after that i got
married i came home and got married and
i i didn't take a lot of thought who i
was marrying you know um
i wanted i was a little bit older
missionary most of them leave when
they're 19. i was 25
um and i felt like i need i love this
girl
and for about six months it was fun you
know
um she was a stripper an ex-stripper i
didn't know before we got married and
all that came out later
but either way uh uh
after that six months she got pregnant
with my first son solomon
and
it just kind of went downhill
um
a lot of
drugs and alcohol
um a lot of turmoil a lot of
a lot of uh
we're very toxic when we're around each
other and it wasn't fair for my kids i
end up having three three children with
this woman
and i still love her today um
in 2016 unfortunately she passed away
she had a drug overdose
and a lot of times i feel like it's my
fault
however
i have a periodic
moments of comfort
um
felt by the spirit of god
confirming to me that
it isn't my fault and that he still
loves me
and i still have a chance you know
um
there's a lot of times where i could
have took over and made different
choices you know
ultimately in the end
what happened was
my my kids were living with her we were
separated for a little while and
two of my babies so i have two boys and
a girl
and my baby girl was
days old at this point and and
and the youngest my my middle is
sebastian they both uh
tested positive for for crystal meth
and
in her care
and i and instead of me standing up and
and
going through the system and getting
the rights to my kids
i kind of
chose her over over them
ultimately i chose my the drug over them
and and
that's i have a lot of resentment for
that but uh
but just me sharing that gives me power
you know it it
[Music]
helps me realize of the these weaknesses
that i have
but um
yeah
i guess the biggest
reason why i think i'm out here is
because i feel like i never had the
opportunity to be a father
and uh
i think every man that has children
needs that opportunity
i don't think it was ever given to me to
fully take the reins
of these children
um they're in my brother's care at this
point
and they call
my brother's wife mom which that's
that's fine you know
i'm grateful that they're with family
but i do miss them
i i didn't see them for christmas again
choices that i made
but i feel like
it can change it can change as long as
as long as i'm i'm humble and i'm ready
to make that change you know and it's
not that far away there's a lot of hope
still left
in my heart so
how old are you how are you stephen
i'm 38 38. and you've been homeless for
how long
so it
since cove it happened i had an
apartment in phoenix
uh i was on a lease
i was sober i actually worked all the 12
steps for the first time
and uh
and then all of a sudden this aaa
program which which thrives off
of
service working and
and helping the other alcoholic who
still suffers that's how the program
works
gave me only one option and that was
attend a meeting on zoom
and
i use that as a reason to go get high
again and
since 2000
20 20 last year
i
chose not to have a residency
i've also chose not to have a a phone
plugged in
um i'm an artist so i i do all kinds of
art for instance
[Applause]
the simple picture right here i just
ripped off
it can be a 3d piece of art it's pretty
easy if you can make his face pop out
just by folding the paper
and you could see
all of a sudden there is you know what i
mean
and and
i like doing art because it gives me an
opportunity to create something
and i feel like my heavenly father gave
me that ability
you know and and it's it's another
opportunity to share about him with
other people
but uh
back to your question
about
um
when i was how long i've been homeless
it's been about a year and a half now
that i've chose not to have a residency
or
or have a
a phone and and i think
i'm realizing now after a year and a
half
these these days fly by um
it's like i'm in this
weird
nightmare that just
i remember bits and pieces of like days
before and then
next year i know it's like a month went
by you know and i didn't accomplish
anything
i'm still doing the same thing that i
was doing a year late earlier
and
that in itself is is
degrading it's not degrading but it's
it
there's a lot of uh remorse there you
know a lot of uh
like i wanna i want that to change
and when i see it's not changing it's
like what do i do
you know our our thinking our regular
thinking leaves when we get in a
situation like this and we become we
become
almost like a zombie where we
our choices all of a sudden are the same
choices and we know what the solution is
we know what we can do and but we choose
not to you know and and i don't know why
it's like that why it lasts for
such a long time but
i want it to change and and
you know i'm willing to do that um
i guess what's driving me what's keeping
me out here is i i feel with with my art
i can
be my own business leader
you know but i have to be sober in order
to do that
and i haven't lined those things up yet
but i you know i feel like
this new year's coming and why not give
it a shot so so yesterday i i started
this 30 day program
to where where i'm not doing any more
crystal meth that's the main thing
i'm being accountable but every day i'm
bringing a service to somebody and i'm
expressing my art
and whatever service that is
and i i'm doing something
i guess out of the box so yesterday was
day one
and i was here the overpass at the i-5
right down the road by the greyhound
station here in la
and
i painted day one kind of on under this
overpass
then i jumped up on this overpass and
was just kind of hanging did a couple
pull-ups
and realized that i can that could be a
mini art show you know
and i have these ideas in my mind
and but i just need to channel it and
and have you know a little bit
slower i guess you say
in marine corps we say fast is smooth
and smooth as fast you know or slow slow
it's smooth and smooth as fast there you
go
and sometimes i i
i feel like i'm just running in circles
did you feel like your life kind of went
off the rails after your military
time or were there problems before yeah
yeah yeah i i think i think that's kind
of you know in the marine corps
i i adapted to what they had and that
was alcohol
you know
there was many times where i blacked out
in the marine corps or
you know drank a whole 18 pack in one
day like
but alcohol is not my drug of choice and
i don't even drink alcohol today
um
but but i did that because that's what
was offered and
and it's just a weird thing that that we
can go to war and die for our country
and
i mean and
they just feed us this alcohol like it's
a solution you know
um i went to uh
to uh
what is it called
it's kind of like a
foreign foreign wars veteran vfw type
thing
in florida recently
and i was i was i went there just
seeking some kind of help because i i'm
a combat vet
and
it was a bar
and all they did was like here have a
drink here sit down
and i just was like what
what is with this man like
it's like they're dumbing us and they
don't want us to
i don't know my feelings about the va
the reason i'm not connected with the va
because
veteran affairs is not veteran help it's
veteran affairs
they're staying in your life it's it's
another reason
for
men to die for their country is the va
is the way i look at it
and and for how they took care of me i
have a good conduct medal and a bad
conduct discharge
and my conduct in the marine corps was
not bad
in fact i went above and beyond i have
11 ribbons i went above and beyond
i was the point man when we're on foot
this is my second deployment in old four
in fallujah
the the same time that scout sniper guy
that american sniper the movie that same
i was in that same place he was
and i was the gunner i was a point man
on foot and i was a gunner on the on the
on the vehicle
and both positions are the most
vulnerable position for my team and i
did that because none of these other men
were going to do it
and um
that itself
demo some kind of service after you get
out
and uh
i came home and and you know i popped on
this piss test and i just kind of left
the marine corps for 28 days
because i didn't want to go back for a
third time
and
they put me on restriction and i went
and smoked some marijuana on restriction
so they threw me in the brig
and here i am in the brig after after
these these tours
amongst
people that are not an expeditionary
these other marines and i'm getting
treated like a you know
and then i got out with a bad kind of
discharge they just wanted to get me out
you know and i i never
uh challenged that i never went to to
get that upgraded
so i feel like that's the biggest thing
that's holding me back is is upgrading
my discharge once once i can just get
that taken care of or at least on the
way of getting taken care of
i feel like
that'll build some confidence and that
goes a long way for me
what's your biggest regret
uh
my biggest regret is is not stepping up
and and taking care of my kids
um
the cool thing about it is that they're
still young
and i'm still alive
how old are you kids
um
the oldest is tan
and then i have solomon and sebastian
sebastian
nine
and i have a little baby girl
and uh
right after their mom passed away
they were
placed with my brother
he was stationed in sierra vista in
arizona at the time and
um
he got stationed in germany right after
that
so my kids went to germany for three
years
so that time after
she died my kids are in another country
those three years kind of really broke
me you know
and uh
if i could go back in time i would go
back to to when that happened and i i
would change the choices i made
um
[Music]
and hopefully it would be a different
outcome but i feel like i can still be
part of their life it's not the
situation i want it to be but
it's still i still deserve to be their
dad and be part of their life you know
you still talk with your family
yeah so
um
actually once covered happened i went
i left phoenix
because i didn't believe what was going
on and i don't believe what the news was
saying i wanted to go see it for myself
and it's kind of if i can relate
anything to being out here
to to
i guess normal life normal people is is
i'm not
one to take someone's word for it
especially if it comes off a media
source
and so
i decided i was going to go see my my
family
um
and i lived with my my mom again for
the first time in
20 years
for three months and i realized i
couldn't live with my mom and
it wasn't the best situation you know
but i'm just a growner man and i didn't
want to live with her and
that's when i i went
from there to spokane and then to
florida
because i got remarried right after my
wife died in 2018 so two years later
yeah so uh
kind of what happened with me with uh
once cold would happen
it happened in march right and and
july 4th is when i left phoenix i was
living in phoenix had my own apartment
and i i
i wanted to relate to to normal people
i guess i'm the type i i need to see it
myself these days especially today
i i have to i have to go i'm not gonna
believe it and it's gonna you know i
didn't i didn't believe all this was
happening all over the world so i went
home and i saw my
my mother still lives where i grew up in
washington
and uh
i decided to live with her for for a
little bit you know
and uh
my last actual on paper job was picking
peppers in my hometown
and it was a seasonal job but you know i
loved it
and
i was living with her and i realized
it's hard to live with your parents
especially when you're 38 years old
so
so i decided to go see my my just this
other woman that i got married to right
after
and i i mean i could back up a little
bit
i haven't been i got married again after
my wife died in 2018
okay and i felt like i just wanted to
get to love somebody and
you know and it was
too fast of a marriage and i didn't know
this woman i married
to she's a
immigrant from the dominican republic
anyway uh she uh haven't seen her in
over a year prior to me
leaving my mom's house okay
once i left my mom's house i went to
florida to finalize a divorce it was
actually the day before
uh valentine's day
for some reason i was like this is what
i'll do for valentine's day i'll
divorce her
and
the power of this drug okay
i went from from wanting to do that in
february
to waking up on the beach
in october
not accomplishing anything i i went from
spokane to daytona
i drove it in 47 hours
and i i was in daytona beach for for six
months
on a
a ferris wheel
if you will
not doing anything
realize one thing though like that i can
make money sketching people on a beach
and i ran with that and and i fed that
into my addiction
and uh
i would make
enough money to go get another sack you
know
and if instead of being disciplined and
working at least a half a day
i would triple my my the intake
income
but but no discipline there
um
fire fueled by an addiction
and
marijuana
and meth
and i feel like
uh i
you know i had a kind of a breakdown
recently
for the first time in a long time
um
where i ended up in the hospital
and uh
so i made a decision to leave florida
there was no reason i was there
you know and
to
come see some family so
on the 11th of
this month i uh
got into phoenix but this is the erratic
thinking that
this drug will do for you
i went from phoenix to la i stayed on
the bus and thought well i don't need to
be in phoenix there's more people in la
i don't have no family here so i came to
l.a you know i'm an artist i make little
pictures really big on walls and i do
portraits and i do abstract i love it
but since the 11th and today i believe
is the 27th
i've been here and haven't done anything
um
like i said earlier i started this this
30-day program yesterday but that's just
one day sober you know um if i can get
10 days sober i i'm starting to wake up
but it's not going to be until about 90
days to where i'm starting to actually
think like somebody that's normal
you know um
and these erratic choices so my brother
bought me a greyhound ticket and i
haven't talked to this brother in a long
time and and
he was happy to hear from me and he's
like i'll give you he's like everyone
deserves a second chance
and that was on the 11th of december and
i haven't called them back since
i
and
christmas just came and went it was just
another day and
you know we have all this hype oh we're
going to do this and this we're going to
change this for christmas i'm gonna see
my kids
the day comes and it's like there's no
ambition
you get i get
bert's burst of ambition and motivation
but it doesn't last long because i'm
always feeding that into my addiction
and then i'll i'll i'll forget or i'll
i'll not be motivated anymore all of a
sudden my whole
way of thinking changes for that day
and
and i lost that day
you can't get that day back
it's kind of been happening like this
you can't get these days back
every breath that we have is grant to us
and i feel like
if i stay on this road it's not going to
be very long to where i'm not
i'm not gonna be on this in this
existence anymore
and
i want i want that to be different i
want to wake up in the morning in a bed
to get up and
when it's raining outside not to worry
about what's going to get wet what's not
you know
i think it's it's good to be to have a
house you know but
you don't have to be
plugged in like everybody else and have
a nine-to-five job and do all you know i
can still be a business owner and have a
home
um
i feel like those are all still within
my reach i just uh
i need i need to
gain some
time between my last use is the biggest
thing so i can start making better
choices
you think staying down here on skid row
lessens your chances of staying clean
i think yeah if i'm down here by on skid
row i i i don't have a fighting chance
um i gotta
first i gotta remove myself from
whatever that drug is you know
and uh
there's gonna be
some maybe some intervention i don't i
don't think the intervention is
necessary as long as i'm
grounded in in a routine and have some
structure
and i think that i can provide that
um
but until i actually
do that that's that structure on a daily
basis
and have a couple people that i'm
accountable to that's the other thing
about
this addiction if you're not accountable
to somebody it's really easy to go
relapse
and so
as long as i'm
accountable and have some structure you
know and those things are provided with
with like inpatient help right
um
i feel like that it eventually i'm going
to be out in the real world so why go
through that that 30 days i feel like
i'll be wasting that 30 days you know
but in reality it might be a a big help
for me
give me that thinking back that i need
with getting out of here getting on a
bus somewhere to another town another
city
yeah so
my whole plan my whole story for my
brother
about him helped me with this ticket
was because i lived in in phoenix for 14
years
and
for the first time since 2007
my license is now good and valid in
phoenix
you know
one of the good things i did after kobe
do is i went home and took care of an
old
misdemeanor dui that i had
and uh
so my whole plan was to come in phoenix
and and you know get my license and
i haven't collected any of my stimulus
money yet you know i was gonna do that
you need a residence you know you need
to be somewhere stable to where you can
two weeks later you can get that money
you know so
i've been waiting to
to get some sobriety time first you know
but i i think like those things are
gonna happen
[Music]
now my plan is to go back to phoenix
this drug was to make you forget about
your plans and do something that you
didn't plan on doing and that's kind of
what happened with me these last
14
15 days that i've been here you know
um
but but i i actually got my bus ticket
right now
to go back to phoenix okay so
i've been kind of waiting to do that um
my my father's in phoenix you know i
want to see him
and you know the
the other bad thing about
this addiction is you hurt your people
you love the most you know
and uh
and they're also the ones that it's the
hardest to gain the trust back
and i feel like
my dad should give me that trust back
right away and he he hasn't yet
so i have a little resentment towards
that that's part of the reason i didn't
want to stay in phoenix or stop there
you know
but he just has his best interest in
mind for me and
it's something i need to get over and
grow up already
so my plan is to get back to phoenix um
i want to get plugged in there's a
there's a sober living home there that i
was living before it's called the hope
house it's a really good program uh it's
structure
i'll be around other dudes that are
working the steps um
obviously you get a sponsor to attend a
meeting i have no idea where a meeting
is here i have nowhere to even look i
i'd highly recommend getting away from
here
absolutely just get lost go anywhere
yeah go phoenix go san diego central
just go somewhere
but this this is the worst place you
could possibly be
if you're trying to get clean yeah i i
you know when every city has uh their
skid row you know and yeah it's
everywhere but but here this is
yeah this is on steroids it is
but yeah that's that's my plan and then
i started this 30-day program just to
help myself be accountable to somebody
you know
and something i can mark down and say
okay it's day three yeah
i haven't used today
i haven't used today so i'm grateful for
that there's a lot of signs that you're
moving in the right direction which is
great
stephen what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
um
don't take for granted the
little luxuries that we have
you know when you
get your kids from school and
get them out of the car seat and stuff
like those things are special you know
and uh
value i value family and one thing i
learned is um family's not necessarily
who you grew up with and
who your brothers and sisters are
families
um we're all family um
we all come from the same
supreme creator as far as i'm concerned
and
i realize that there's a lot of good
people out here still
and
the world's not
all in despair you know
um
i i think that
not taking those things for granted and
and realizing that it was if you treat
people the way you want to be treated
the stuff that they teach us when we're
younger you know the golden rule it goes
a long way when you're when you're on
the streets
um things come back to you and then
one thing i learned in iraq was uh
god does answer prayers
and and and that's one thing that's
becoming more evident to me
out here on the streets
and he does he does care about us he's
very mindful
of who we are and what we're going
through
all right stephen
thank you so much for sharing your story
i wish you lots of luck with
what you're doing
thank you
man so i was starting to cry
you